pour changer un peu les idées beauourg
faites avec nous une visite à beauourg
déé mais bourg admiré puisque près de
700000 Français ont visité le Centre
Pompidou depuis son ouverture il y a
moins d'un mois et demi 10 à 15000
personnes vont chaque jour à beauourg
parce que beauourg qu'on aime ou qu'on
naime pas est devenu comme la Tourel une
des grandes curiosités
nationalesourg pour toucher beauourg
pour sentir beauour peut-être pourvoir
beauour et sourire comme l'a fait
notreorteur
christianou
[Musique]
voilà
écoutez
lire
jouer
comprendre
Satir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
PC de t02 suis au niveau 6350 face à
l'escalator montant 4e 5e répondez bien
compris votre position02 nous av
[Musique]
enregistré
il mett des rideaux
[Musique]
intérieur il reste très peu de temps
pour place à la caisse sous au bas de
l'Escal situ
princip dans quelques minutes
[Musique]
Inés je pas c'est
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]